(whooshing)
- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today, we're talking about the power
of shifting your perspective.
And also, as you're watching,
if you hear something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below,
and put it in quotes so other people
can be inspired as well,
and when you write
something down yourself,
it's much more likely to
stick for you as well.
Enjoy.
(playful inspirational music)
(inspirational music)
- Because a lot of you, for real,
you're not where you want to be.
You're thinking of negative stuff.
You're talking negativity, right?
You're in that negative zone.
You're feeding off of negativity.
You're talking to negative people.
You're watching negative stuff,
and I need you to do me a favor.
I need you to know that,
in order for you to get
to that next level, you got
to change your thinking,
like for real.
You don't need no money.
You don't need no stuff.
The one thing you need to do
to go where you've never gone before,
to have what you've never had before,
is to change the way you think.
(inspirational music)
- This could be the
greatest time you ever live
if you control what you focus on,
if you find a more empowering meaning,
and if you decide to
model the actions of those
who succeeded before you.
It can be the best financial time,
the best emotional time,
the best spiritual time of your life,
but you better take control of your state.
So, if you want to change
your life, my friends,
you've got to change your physiology
and you got to change your focus.
By the way, how fast can
you change that stuff?
How fast, my friends?
How fast?
How fast? Come on.
In a heartbeat, once your
re-change your conditioning.
That's all you got to do,
and you can do it fast.
You can do it a question or two.
Try this right now.
Answer this question in
your mind, and be honest.
What, in your life today,
if you wanted to be,
could you feel proud about right now?
If you wanted to feel proud.
If you feel like I shouldn't be proud.
If you wanted to feel proud,
what could you be proud
of in your life today?
Your children, your health, your body?
Is there a problem you faced,
and instead of running from it,
you finally stepped up and handled it?
What could you feel proud
of in your life today,
if you wanted to feel proud?
How many could think of something?
And when you think about
this thing you're proud of,
what about that makes you feel proud?
What do you focus on that
makes you feel proud?
How do you breathe when you
really start to feel proud?
What's the kind of look on
your face that starts to happen
when you let yourself feel proud?
Yeah, how's that feel?
Think of another area of life.
Think of an area of life
that you're grateful for,
or if you go I'm not grateful,
if you wanted to be grateful,
what's an area you
could feel grateful for?
What could you feel grateful for,
if you really wanted to feel grateful?
If you wanted to be excited
about your life right now,
and you were willing to be excited,
you were willing to buck
everybody else's trend,
what could you feel
excited about in your life
if you wanted to feel excited?
What could you get excited about
if you really focused on it
and you really took it in?
And you weren't in a negative place?
What could you get excited about,
if you wanted to be excited in your life?
Or when you're really
excited, how do you feel?
How do you speak?
What's your life like?
By the way, when you're excited,
does it tend to touch
other people, yes or no?
Absolutely.
By the way, do people have a tendency,
but who feels different right now
than just even a couple moments ago?
Raise your hand, say I.
Why? Because focus is
controlled by questions.
If you ask a different
question continuously,
not once, continuously,
you will get a different answer.
If you ask a lousy question,
you get a lousy answer
and a lousy state.
Somebody said why does
this always happen to me?
It doesn't always happen to you,
but the brain's like a computer.
Ask it a question, it'll have
to come up with an answer.
'Cause you deserve it, you idiot.
Someone will say how come
I can never lose weight?
You can lose weight,
but if you keep saying
how come I can't ever lose weight,
the brain's got to come with an answer,
goes you're a pig.
Lousy question create what?
Lousy answers.
Ask a better question,
get a better answer.
Now, here's what I want you to get.
I want you to get that
you can change your state,
how fast, guys?
How fast?
And if you get the habit of doing it,
you'll have a different life.
- I was in an advising
session with a student, right?
Man, I wish you guys
could have been there.
So, I'm sitting with the student, right?
And I begin to pull out my paperwork,
and I'm about to share
with her her math grade,
but before I could even open up my mouth,
you know what she said to me?
Don't even talk about it.
That's right, she told
me, ET, the motivator,
don't even talk about it.
What she was saying was look,
I'm not trying to be disrespectful,
but I already know I'm not
doing that well in math.
My teacher has talked to me about it.
I've got a tutor, and guess what?
ET, the motivator, there's
no way you can help me
with this situation, so she said to me
let's not even talk about it,
and I'm telling some of
you out there right now,
the reason why you are in
the situation you're in,
because you keep talking about negativity.
You keep talking about stuff
that you can't do anything
about, so principle number two,
real short and real sweet,
don't even talk about it,
and you know what?
I'm going to throw a tip in with that.
Not only don't talk about it,
but there's some things you
should even listen to, alright?
Negativity, the things that
people are coming to you with
that you know you can't change.
There's nothing you can do about it.
Don't just not talk about it,
don't listen to it.
I want you to know that,
from wherever you are,
wherever you are, you can get
to where you need to get to
from that spot, right?
I want to share something with you.
Most of you guys know I was homeless
for two and a half years, right?
Homeless for two and a half years,
and a high school dropout,
but one day, I just made up in my mind
that I was not going
to allow homelessness,
I was not going to allow
being a high school dropout,
that to define who I was,
and so I said you know what, Eric?
It's manageable.
It's manageable, but what you got to do,
man, some of you, you
live seven days at a time.
You live 30 days at a time,
and I had to say to myself,
Eric, you can do this, but you know what?
You're going to have to
do this one day at a time.
That's right, one day at a time,
and so I started studying for my GED,
one day at a time, and I went
from a high school dropout
to a college graduate,
to getting my masters,
and working on my PhD.
I went from being homeless
to being a homeowner,
so I want you to know, you can do it,
but you got to break it up in pieces.
That's right, take your
rent one month at a time.
Take your life one day at a time,
and I guarantee, if you
take it one day at a time,
you will see how manageable it is,
and one day you will look
up and you can get up.
- I was a garbage man, like Troy.
You get eight hours worth of work,
but you can do it in three,
so you can go home as soon as you finish.
Post office, you get
three hours worth of work,
and you make it last eight.
I did both.
I liked being the garbage man better,
but they weren't bad jobs.
It's like when people
say oh, the difficulty
of making a movie.
I'm like send your son to Iraq.
That's difficult.
It's just a movie.
It's like, relax, I don't
play that precious nonsense.
Oh, a movie, oh, get out of here.
You know?
Your son got shot in the face?
That's difficult.
Making a movie is a luxury.
It's a gift.
It's an opportunity, and most
importantly, it's a gift.
Obviously, everybody here is
talented enough to do that,
but don't get it twisted.
It's just a movie.
It ain't that big a deal.
- In the dark times, it's the easiest time
to curl up in a ball, and
sometimes that's okay.
If you need to have a bad day
and sit on the couch and
watch a bunch of movies
with some tissues, and
just go through a bad day
and a few bags of potato chips, you know?
A lot of people have to
deal with that situation,
and it's okay,
but if that happens day after
day after day after day,
that's the time to take
control of your life back,
or ask for some help, you know?
Part of perspective isn't
just understanding our life
has been better, understanding
that we have strengths
and choice and will.
It's understanding that
we aren't the only thing.
That perspective reminds
us there's other people
out in the world who we might
be able to connect with.
who can help us.
To raise our hand and
connect with a friend
or take somebody out for
lunch or to call a therapist
or to get some support from other people,
other family, other
friends, it's important.
That's part of perspective as well.
I would say, you know,
what else comes to mind
when there's a difficult time is to ask
what should I be learning here,
because sometimes, when it's
really difficult in life,
we don't feel competent.
We don't feel capable.
We feel like, you know, we
don't have any personal power.
We don't have any knowledge of
how to proceed through there,
so I tell people, when
you're in a difficult time,
create like a learning map.
You know, like okay, based on everything
that's going on right
now, what are three things
I need to start learning right now?
You know, what can I
learn from this situation?
That's always powerful, right?
That's one powerful way to learn.
Well, what can I learn from here?
What's the universe sending
a message to me right now?
What can I learn from this situation,
from my behavior or my beliefs?
From my interactions with other people?
But also, going to that next step
and saying okay, at this point,
what should I start learning in my life?
And I know it sounds so weird, you know?
I'm not saying hey, you know,
you're really depressed.
It's time to start learning French.
But you know what?
It might help you, because in the process
of learning something, our
brain starts activating
in different ways that
also end up activating
other parts of our brain's
capabilities to grow,
to cope, to deal.
A great time to start learning again
is the times when you feel just beaten up
and kicked by the side of the road.
It's time to stand up and say okay,
what would I need to learn
now to advance my life
to the next stage?
Because look, no matter where you're at,
if you're in a difficult
place in life right now,
realize you've been in the last stage,
and now there's going to be a new stage,
so what will you have to learn
or master in this new stage
to feel better about
yourself or about life,
or get ahead a little bit more.
Don't forget that.
- The way I handle things,
even in the few rare days
when I really struggle,
I take a real step back and make pretend
that somebody called me and told me that
my mother or daughter were killed.
And I know that's very
dark, and I apologize,
but it's really what I do.
I literally am able to, at my deepest,
most struggling moment within business,
take a step back and remind myself
that I can make a
drillion dollars tomorrow
on bitcoin, and
if something bad happened to
the people I love the most,
that it would mean nothing,
and it very consistently
rewires me very quickly.
I just put business in perspective.
At the end of the day,
you know, it's money.
For me, it's not really
money, it's my legacy,
so I get hurt by it a little bit more, but
yeah, I mean, you know,
I put it in perspective.
It's money, and you know what?
Up until I had a daughter,
even while I was married,
up until when I had Misha four years ago,
I secretly wanted to lose all my money.
I had this weird, twisted, dark fantasy
of losing everything just
to rise again like a phoenix
and remind you.
- So, if we're going
to talk about the power
of shifting your perspective,
I think, in general,
people focus on the wrong things.
I think, in general, most
people focus on the small things
in their life, in their business,
the things that are most immediate things,
that are most in front of their face,
and it makes us play small
on a consistent basis.
One of the most effective
strategies that I've found
to help overcome an immediate
situation of despair
or anger, frustration, is to be grateful,
'cause you can't be grateful
and upset at the same time.
If you're truly grateful and appreciative
of what's happening,
then you can't be upset
at the same time, so as an example,
last week, I'm at my condo and
I'm waiting for the elevator,
and it's just taking a really long time.
I've got some heavy things.
I can't take the stairs,
and so I'm waiting.
Really frustrated that
the elevator hasn't come.
I think one of the
elevators is on service,
and there must be a lot of
people going up and down.
It's like I'm sitting there,
waiting for the elevator.
I'm like when is the
elevator going to come?
How often have you been in that situation,
where you're waiting for the elevator,
you're stuck in traffic,
or somebody is late,
or somebody has let you down?
And instead, I quickly
shifted my perspective,
and I asked myself how can I turn this
into a moment of appreciation?
How can I trade my
expectations for appreciation?
And I just thought of listen,
we've got these elevators,
these magical boxes that
can transport us up and down
flights of stairs so that
I don't have to carry
these heavy boxes, and
I have to wait, you know
30 seconds more for that
elevator to come down.
That immediately shifted my perspective
to focus on what I do have,
what I'm grateful for, instead
of focusing on the problem
that I had, which is not
really that big a problem.
And I think we can, in
general, do that for our life.
Look at what you're so upset about.
Look at what's causing you
so much massive frustration?
The fact that you're
even watching this video
means that you are better off
than 95% of the people in the world,
where people can't even, you
know, give themselves food
or have a stable job, have no,
you know, income coming in.
They don't have an education.
Most of the people in the
world, you are better off than.
There are a lot of people
who have started businesses
and had way more success
in what you've done,
and they started with way fewer resources
than what you currently have right now,
and what do we do, as entrepreneurs?
We tend to focus on what we don't have.
We don't have the finances.
We don't have the resources.
We don't have the education.
We don't have the mentorship.
We don't have the connections.
We don't have, we don't have,
we don't have, we don't have,
and that just continues
that cycle of frustration
and anger and resentment and depression,
and we never get to where we need to go,
where instead, if you
focus on figuring out
what you can do with
what you already have,
and that you already
have enough inside you
to build something amazing,
if you can remind yourself of
that when you get frustrated,
then that can help get
you out of the hole.
That shifting of perspective
can allow you to go off
and do amazing things, where otherwise,
your day was set off down a negative path,
so I hope that helps.
(whooshing)
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
John Dominick asked me to,
so if there's a topic
you'd like me to cover
on the next edition of Believe Life,
please leave it down
in the comments below,
and I will see what I can do.
I also love to know which
rule did you like the best?
What did you learn the most
from watching this video?
What are you going to take from it
that you will immediately
apply somewhere in your life
or your business.
I'd love to learn it.
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
Finally, I want to also
give a quick shout out
to Celia Lopez.
Celia, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word, and
taking that awesome picture
and posting to Twitter.
It really, really means a lot to me,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I hope you have an amazing day.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
(whooshing)
- When you have a down time,
like if something didn't
work the way you want.
What do you do to get
back on that positiveness?
- I talk to the mountain.
I have a mountain next to
my home that is called.
(speaking foreign language)
It's very low.
It goes up to 2004 or 2,500 meters,
or I talk to the
(speaking foreign language)
which is 4,000 meters, which
is a little bit further away
from my home, which I see every morning.
I see those two mountains, and
I say to these two mountains,
mountains, I have a problem,
but when I look at you,
you are 37 million old,
and I'm a little guy.
I'm a little guy here
with a little problem.
Can you help me?
And they will say come on.
Look what we have already
seen in so many years.
Your problem is a nano problem.
Come on, get up.
- Just get up.
Do it.
That's it.